let's talk about some really amazing
benefits using MCT oil first of all what
is MCT oil it's medium chain
triglycerides it's a unique oil that
will not just turn into ketones very
rapidly and give you energy but it has
the ability to bypass certain digestive
processes as compared to other fats so
in other words you don't need bile from
the gallbladder to help you digest MCT
oil it just goes straight in so you can
use it so it has the ability of spiking
ketones
now a couple drawbacks to MCT oil when
you first start consuming it it could
give you some digestive troubles or pain
in your abdomen so you always want to
consume small amounts maybe a half of a
teaspoon at first and then slowly go up
to a teaspoon or maybe a tablespoon the
other challenge is that it may have a
laxative effect on you but for most
people it's a very mild thing despite
all the positive things when you consume
MCT oil your body is going to turn that
into ketones not necessarily your own
body fat so it may slow down your weight
loss but it's a really good thing to
start out with to allow you to do in a
minute fasting especially in the morning
so when you put in your coffee for
example you'll be able to go a lot
longer without having to eat so it's
very satisfying and the last negative
thing about it is that it's a refined
product it doesn't have a lot of
nutrients so it basically is used for
fuel so in addition to MCT oil you want
to eat healthy too you don't want to
just consume MCT oil to get you in
ketosis without you know considering all
the nutrients that you need all right
that being said one of the benefits well
first of all you're gonna have a better
brain function especially if your brain
is damaged and you're having Alzheimer's
or epilepsy or Parkinson's the ketones
generated from MCT oil will penetrate
the brain and you'll have better
cognition memory focus concentration
okay number two increase energy so
you're gonna have more energy especially
in the head
all right so that's a good benefit
number three better lipid profile
because MCT oil has no carbohydrates
despite it being a fat you're gonna find
it doesn't increase insulin and your
cholesterol is going to look better the
LDL is gonna look better the HDL is
going to look better now number four
lowered blood sugar so this is really
good to help stabilize someone if they
have if they're a pre-diabetic or
diabetes or they have insulin resistance
so it's gonna help your blood Sugar's
why because the body is gonna be running
on ketones not blood sugar so it takes
the stress off the pancreas alright
number five reduced hunger this is a
huge benefit your hunger is gonna go
away it's gonna make doing this program
a lot easier so I always recommend it
especially in the beginning just to
increase the time between meals so you
can fast longer number six decrease
lactate that's generated after exercise
so if you're an athlete and you need
endurance what will short-circuit that
is the amount of lactic acid and lactate
that is produced and that's gonna cause
a problem with cramping in the muscle so
if you can run more on ketones from MCT
oil you'll be able to decrease this and
have more endurance so your performance
will be much better number seven
decrease epileptic episodes so if you
have epilepsy and you're getting these
seizures ketones will bypass the part of
the brain that's damaged and you will
reduce these episodes alright number
eight improve cardiovascular function if
you have congestive heart failure
angina atrial fibrillation any problem
with the heart especially the heart
muscle itself ketones from MCT oil will
bypass the damaged heart cells and feed
the heart ketones directly and your
heart will be very very happy and it'll
function better alright number nine it
decreases the symptoms of autism because
there's usually some damaged part of the
brain that is causing this problem and
so by adding ketones
like I said with this point right here
if you have Alzheimer's or Parkinson's
or autism taking ketones will be very
beneficial to help reduce the symptoms
all right ten MCT oil has antimicrobial
properties so if you have Candida or
some viruses or a fungus this would be
the thing to do now as a side note when
you consume coconut oil it has lauric
acid which is really good for the immune
system so if you had a microbial problem
you might want to do just straight
coconut oil because it has some benefits
from something called lauric acid and it
has additional medium chain
triglycerides that would benefit you
alright number eleven MCT oil has
anti-inflammatory properties so it's
going to help reduce inflammation
ketones are anti-inflammatory ketones
are they act as an antioxidant so it's
going to help you and that's the next
one it gives you antioxidant properties
which is going to counter the free
radical damage thirteen it's going to
increase the mood so not only are you
going to improve the cognitive function
but your overall mood will go up because
your brain is happier 14 increase the
absorption of fat cyber vitamins fat
type of vitamins get absorbed with other
oils and fats that you consume so if you
were to take your cod liver oil for
example or any type of fat soluble
vitamins whether it's vitamin E or k2
while you're taking MCT oil this MCT oil
will help the absorption it will also
help the absorption of the DHA and EPA
those are omega-3 fatty acids and 15
taking MCT oil will make the transition
into a full ketosis much smoother
because it'll give the brain more
ketones and you're gonna have less brain
fog and it'll allow you to transition
smoother because sometimes when you
transition over especially like the
first day or second day you're not going
to be in a hundred percent ketosis
you'll be like 30% 40% 50% so take
MCT oil gives you the ketones that will
make you feel like you're in 100%
ketosis all right there you have it the
15 benefits of MCT oil if you're liking
this content please subscribe now and I
will actually keep you updated on future
videos